here we are here we are you know I hope
you're well I hope you're well and man
I'm just I'm just an egomaniac with a
inferiority complex somebody said that
once and man I've worn that ever since
like a I think when I heard that thing
it fit my ears like a just like a damn
comfortable shirt man I'm an egomaniac
with an inferiority complex
yeah she's got she's been bring a man to
his knees
Bishop gun right here you never see your
common that's how I know
[Music]
the devil has Obama
well mr. Johnson news cuz it's not her
pulse in the Delta Delta baby said ma'am
if you don't mind would you tune this
guitar for me well [ __ ] [ __ ] soon and
she broke his heart
[Music]
temptation anything that's a good one
that's a good one there and you can
listen to the rest of that one that is
Bishop Gunn and that's their song devil
is a woman and yeah man is the devil a
woman
there are things male and female I find
that they are I like to think if you
think about the devil being a because
the devil is that it's a it's the
temptation you know the devil you could
feel your train just my train will be on
the tracks man I'm cruising you know
doing good things for myself waving at a
neighbor having a milk having a fresh
milk you know doing nothing bad nothing
I see maybe a bowl of caramels or
weathers originals I pass them up I'm
good I'm good baby I'm cool I'll go for
a run I go for a jog you know I'll wave
it a neighbor pet a puppy you know
tickle a buck tickle tickle a dove and
then suddenly my train the tracks they
roll right past that temptation station
and the Satan's little cat house right
there and my brakes they I don't even
put the brakes on but they put
themselves on
my brakes don't put them like who's
running the brakes and that's a
temptation man temptation is such a
dangerous it's such a dangerous little
microwave isn't it because it looks warm
in there it looks fun it's lit up you
open that microwave it looks lit up in
there and then you walk in there the
door closes the star things start
cooking the floor starts spinning around
in a circle you got all that your loved
ones are looking in at the window a
temptation man at a beta it'll beta and
the middle damn date chip run next thing
you know you're trapped into a
relationship with the devil and that is
devil as a woman by Bishop Gunn and they
have their festival coming up I know in
Natchez Mississippi next weekend not
this weekend but I believe the 11th is
the date I don't know if I'm gonna be
there I'm gonna try to get there but I'm
also gonna try to get some rest and but
it's a bit of gunk crawfish boil they do
it this is a second year they've done it
and I'm just so proud of them you know
they're to me they're like a southern
Aerosmith and you know the drummer some
people don't know I've told the story
before I'll tell it fast the drum race
to work with his father his father had a
farm over there and the along the
Mississippi Louisiana border and I used
to work on the farm in the summertime
and his dad you know his dad really
cared about me when I didn't have
someone to care about me sometimes or
just his dad was a man a male presence
that was around that I could that just
let me that let me feel okay around him
you know that didn't really judge me and
just let me feel okay and uh and we were
friends for years and his father passed
away from addiction and the son who I've
known since he was probably - he was
he's been in some bands over the years
and I didn't you know somebody says
they're a drummer for a couple years
you're like damn they they're like yeah
I'm in a band
and you're like well damn he's doing
drugs you know but he stayed with those
sticks and this dude will [ __ ] put a
tambourine out of business brother this
young fella can play the drums and they
got a they have an amazing band and and
now he's in this band Bishop gun and and
it's just been a blessing to see my
friend's son get to live out some of his
dreams anyway what's going on I'm back I
was in West Palm this weekend I want to
announce these tour dates oh wait I just
did announce him we'll put that at the
beginning let me announce him now I'll
announce him now so we don't have to
edit anything in here just some new Dark
Arts we got some new Dark Arts tour
dates some of the cities now if you've
come to the show you know a year ago
some of the materials going to be the
same has changed some new stories but
it's just some places we didn't get to
see everybody there so I'll be going to
Vancouver Seattle Portland Boise San
Antonio Austin Tulsa Oklahoma City those
are all in June then I'll be going in
August to Sakura mento Las Vegas Memphis
Atlanta Louisville Biloxi Sayreville New
Jersey over there at the Starland
Ballroom bethlehem PA where the Lord was
born baby over there at the sands
Bethlehem Event Center Oxon Hill
Maryland have you tired of getting
gunned down over there in DC or or you
know getting stuck in a traffic for them
busy libraries you go over to oxen Hill
Cleveland Ohio and I am so excited about
that one Indianapolis I'm excited about
that one Grand Rapids Detroit Milwaukee
and Madison and those are in August and
October and there's going to be some
more dates in the south that are added
but I don't know when just yet all those
tickets go on sale Tuesday this Tuesday
which is the 30th I guess April 30th at
10 a.m. local time
and the presale code is onward so no one
else is gonna have access to these
tickets
except our listeners and people that uh
and we'll probably put a swipe up on
social media but that's going to be it
so you'll be able to get access to these
tickets and and and I'm excited you know
I love the show that I'm able to do
right now and it's business been a blast
I mean it's been a blast man and so
those are the cities and thank you so
much for your patience and I'm excited
you know I'm excited I was in West Palm
this weekend you I got to meet riff raff
Jody high roller that frickin that the
Tanger a tangerine tiger you know what
I'm talking about that raspberry Ralph
Waldo sinner son you feel me man
riff-raff in R Afghanistan and if you
don't know the man I'm took him up Dale
damn Tony with that million-dollar
mullet I mean this guy's got a mullet
that'll it'll make George Washington's
butt sweat you know he got that thing
who it is just that's just got so many
waves in it when he walks by the ocean
you could hear the water get jealous
and he invited me into his uh multimedia
complex over there him and his boy Mike
and man it was something special you
know I know of him through Simon Rex and
I knew of him just you know growing up
and seeing his wildness he's a unique
character he's that Armageddon ostridge
he's a rare in Ponemah they don't have a
lot like him Jody high roller
they call him and he invited me to his
home and we did an episode we did a
podcast episode and it's crazy because I
remember two years ago thinking man it
would be I remember he and I messaged on
Instagram and I was like what I was so
just man I would be crazy if one day I
got to enter an interview and talk with
him just talk with him chop it up and
here I was
you know getting to live out kind of
like a little dream getting to live out
a special moment and he's a special guy
you know he's very artistic and very
unique and and it was just I'm glad I
got to do it it was fun it was it was a
lot of things but you'll see you know we
really chopped it up and talked about
the past and talked about life and we
broke it down town who else we had that
the shows were good dude they had a
[ __ ] wasted guy which show was a
Saturday Late Show it's dude I don't
sunglasses he had his feet up on the
table he I don't know it almost seemed
like he had been you know in prehistoric
times he'd frozen up and then enough
global warming or just a natural local
Sun or just a couple of [ __ ] brave
dudes with some pickaxes that finally
you know got him out of that that ice
block that ice block time locked that
mother nature had put him in that cold
coffin frozenness and let him loose you
know and he this dude was an animal yes
sometimes he'd have sunglasses on and he
would take him off he was yelling the
jokes in the middle he was I mean he
really almost he a lot of people
complained about him he was a real real
piece of [ __ ] dirty work man
Nesta and that's Satan baby right on
your shoulder what is that nothing know
that Satan boy less Satan it was a
special time man it was a special
weekend it was a special weekend you
know I enjoyed it I was grateful that
everybody came out thank you guys for
coming out thank you guys so much for
coming out it really really meant a lot
and Florida is a unique place if you
ever been to Florida then then you
should go you should go dude everything
looks smokeable when you write when you
get there out the airport you're driving
around and everything in Florida looks
like you could roll it up and smoke it
or put it in a piping and change your
change your brain cartography I mean
it's you could do some some remapping of
your interior avenues because everything
in uh in South Florida looks smokeable
man this fella from my old neighborhood
came out this dude dick Dickie Van Zandt
came out Richard was his you know isn't
god-given name but they call him Dickie
and in Van Zandt I don't was his natural
name I think was Van Zandt Van Van
Zant's him but eventually you know you
get a nickname sometimes from people in
an area and over there on Magee Street
in Covington off Ali Road where I you
know sprout it up and this dude he you
know something happened to him I don't
know if he got you know he had some
issues and was you know he had that
thing in his neck where you get that
hole in your neck from smoking or
drinking chemicals sometimes people
drink a [ __ ] you know half a can of
gasoline and next thing you know they
got to talk through that you know you
know they're half of a [ __ ] flute I
mean they put a hole right by their
heart and that you you know they're a
damn they're a wind section of an
orchestra but dvz came out man he got
that smokers hole you know I think from
smoking too many cigars you know and he
could do this trick even did it
he'll swallowed a marble and pop it out
of his throat you know showed a kid
surprised the boy that his soffit Geel
David Blaine boy just BAM and he [ __ ]
pop it right out it's like winning the
marble lottery and he can do it with a
couple things to maybe you think he
stole your wife red and wet wedding ring
he did it on one couple where he said
hey let me see your wife's wedding ring
and the guy's like alright he swallows
it and the dudes like what the hell man
you know a thing cost me half a year's
salary and then before the guy can punch
him he pulls it out of his throat and
makes them realize they love each other
still and that's
power really of the human body right
there in the human spirit so good to see
you D man it was nice bro
it was nice man I miss being young man I
miss it you know I got to see my little
nephews I saw him last week and they
were taught they wanted to play sports
in the street and they collect him bait
they show me their back they're better
football cards and just the excitement
of when everything is new in the world
you know that's one thing I miss
remember when every when regular things
were temptation and you mill around long
enough and then the only person the only
thing that the only you know you've seen
everything enough you've collected
enough basketball card and you know
you've you know you've watched enough
you you know you you've gone to the
beach enough times and you've you know
touch the the nipples of enough ladies
or kissed enough women or or and then
the only temptations around is that it's
this it's really the dark arts at that
point you know the only person that's
still stirring the bowl with the wooden
spoon and you look at the hand you see
that it's got dark nail polish on it and
that's the devil man he's the only one
who's still tempting he's still stirring
you dirty like that so you got to find
those inner temptations you know that's
what I have to find anyway I got to find
you know you got to fight the dark arts
man and I've uh and I'm grateful to see
it these at the shows a lot of people
come I mean the lady told me the other
day they had a beautiful ladies the
manager there at the West Palm Beach
Club
and the club I don't know from from
audience experience what the audience
experience was like but the manager
hard-working woman and and I was I
talking about man I said I'm a
temptation anyway she told me oh yes she
told me after one of the show she said
hey at the end of the weekend could we
got done one thirty one thirty we left
the club after doing meet-and-greets and
uh and just meeting everybody that
wanted to wait she said yeah you have
one of the nicest audiences that that
we've ever had wow that's so cool I said
yeah you know I'm lucky to be part of a
neat group that's what I told her so you
know we do we got a good group we got a
good group except for that one that dark
angel that was out there
this dude was [ __ ] doing lines of his
grandfather's dandruff boy that guy was
[ __ ] built up he was built up on
false stilts doing on that dust on that
like you gotta [ __ ] like you got a
woodpecker living in you
um what else what's going on oh I'll say
this man had a young guy that came Oh an
engagement and engagement I'll put it on
the YouTube I'll send Nick the video a
man came and I can't remember his name I
thought it was Ryan but I could be wrong
he came and he said and he got engaged
to his wife afterwards after the show so
after the first show I've been doing
meet-and-greet where I can meet about 50
people because if we meet everybody
after the first show and then the second
show gets delayed till you know it can
be two hours so we have to limit the
number of people and then after the
second show I'll do a meet-and-greet and
then meet anybody else that wants to
wait that wants to wait it just takes a
while so no people been asking me about
it but it's just the only fair way that
I can think to do it right now because I
can't have the second show start you
know two hours late it needs to try to
start on time and we started at a half
hour late on each show this week but
anyway but you guys won't care about
that only I care about it you know
moisés bothering myself with with myself
but a guy got engaged man this is the
second time I've seen and I was in
Boston and a guy and his girlfriend
walking around all day and he took a
knee right there in front of me and just
and they got engaged I need to reach out
to him too actually and then this other
and in this pair BAM the guy just said
oh he didn't have a ring for he went
that old ringless you know there that
ringless worm no ring she's like you
don't even have a ring but they were
both crying and hugging and then today
she sent me an Instagram photo when she
does have a ring so he must have made up
for it today doing that Sunday shopping
but man that's beautiful huh
that was beautiful
and what else another guy came up and I
was thinking about you know I've been
working in this 12-step stuff that I'm
doing they have you know you think about
you talk about family and people you
have resentments against and things that
are buried inside of you that can like
that can affect the way you behave daily
but you don't realize it you know it's
not like they're treasures but you don't
realize they're treasures at first
because resentments you know they can
really it's like a little edge inside of
you where it's supposed to be a curve
and so everything that goes around there
is choppy every time your thoughts or
your feelings pass through that canal of
that journey within if you're thinking
about something that even is related to
you know a previous experience you had
that you didn't like there or a person
that you don't like or a family member a
loved one or a parent or whatever you
have a resentment so then anytime
something else comes up that would kind
of use one of the same streets in your
brain or your feelings
you know instead of it being a curve
it'll be a you know a 90-degree angle
and it's choppy they're like speed bumps
for the way that you can love others to
me anyway you know I can't love people
as well if I have these speed bumps in
me it makes some kind of the highway out
my heart's got a lot of it's just a you
know it you're gonna have to have really
good insurance if you're gonna travel
down it because I got a lot of speed
bumps on it resentment anger things you
know previous experiences that are rough
that make my road rough and make it
rough for me to bring anybody down the
road and they had him young men that
came after the show and he said hey you
know I really appreciate some of the
stuff you talk about on the podcast when
you get into like just talking about
what you're feeling and stuff you know
my father my father was real old when I
was born you guys know that my dad was
born in 1910 and so I've been doing this
work recently just thinking about my my
dad and my relationship with him and
this young fella at the show said hey
you know my dad was born was 61 and and
that got me thinking even more about
just about my dad and just kind of how
you know I always had you know I'm like
I love my dad I'm grateful for him but
I've also always been a little bit angry
at him I didn't realize it uh I was
always angry because I didn't know him
very well you know I was 16 when he
passed away and he was 86 and uh you
know I was angry because I didn't know
him because he didn't know me you know a
kind of a
was and then I you know I realized that
I really kind of judged my father like I
didn't realize I always thought that so
one of the reasons we didn't know each
other very well was because because of
the age gap but I really started to
think back more on it and one of the
reasons also we didn't know each other
very well was because I really judged
him you know I really judged him for
being so old you know the kids would
make fun of him and then I kind of made
fun of him
and I think sometimes I didn't even try
to get to know him even though I was
young it wasn't my responsibility really
it was it was an ideal situation but I
didn't really try to get to know him you
know when I would have it I would make
the excuse well he shouldn't had a kid
when he was that old you know what was
he thinking well that's true but if he
doesn't have that I don't exist so
there's some validity there to that
argument but but but if I don't if I
don't exist but he gave me my existence
whatever however way it happened you
know he really gave me the only
important the most important gift which
is my experience of the world
and and I judged
and kind of then I didn't really get to
know him you know there were times I he
probably thought sometimes well maybe my
son doesn't he's not interested it or he
he
I think maybe I was afraid to get to
know him because I knew he was going to
pass away so it was probably like safer
to not get to know him you know
but I remember I chose to joke around I
would always make you know cuz other
people started making fun of my dad
because he was just so old man you know
and so I would make fun of him
you know sometimes because it's all I
could do it's the only thing I could do
to kind of survive was to also make fun
of him but but in doing that I didn't
really honor him I didn't really honor
my relationship with him that much I
didn't you know and I'm not really
blaming myself I'm not coming down hard
on myself
I just I'm trying to get to a place
where
where we're not think about fatherhood
and I think about parenting I'm trying
to you know pick these locks that keep
me from
[Music]
having a lot of emotions in those spaces
but I was really embarrassed to my
father you know I hate to say this man I
was embarrassed like uh you know when we
walked somewhere I walk kind of far
behind him or away from him you know
because he was so old I didn't and he
didn't notice that much because you know
when you get old and this one when I was
a kid when I was a kid I was real doting
on him I was real caring you know I
remember we would walk to church
sometimes and I would you know I make
sure that the leaves were off of a
sidewalk and I would make sure that
though that he knew that the I mean a
sidewalk in Louisiana dude good [ __ ]
luck bro that thing is a gangplank dudes
sidewalk in Louisiana that's a side work
they should call it that thing the first
thing is like that the next one is
straight up one of them is a damn
drawbridge because they got all the tree
roots popping through so you have one
piece of cement sidewalk the next piece
is a dam the third piece is off-ramp
take you right over to uh Laplace where
Billy conforto lived r.i.p I mean the
sidewalk in Louisiana thing is dangerous
slip and fall dude slip and fall all the
way into the Lord's arms that thing's
killing senior citizens left and right
that's a side work baby there's no and
sorry ma'am ride and make sure that my
dad knew how the sidewalk was when we
were young so that we could walk
together you know but then as he got
older I remember like we'd be somewhere
now he'd be you know I'd walk away from
him or you know I remember like
I remember like he like you know I
remember like his skin sometimes on his
hands it was real old excuse me I just
cleared my own throat and swallowed my
own mucus so I'm obviously a reptile
[Music]
but I remember his skin on his hands was
so old that sometimes you know when I
saw him who would make me like I loved
him and stuff but it would make me kind
of scared or it would make me
it would make me kind of sad sometimes
you know when he touched me because
you know because he wasn't the way that
I wanted him to be you know and I'm and
I'm not
not said because this I don't think this
is like my fault or not you know I don't
want you to I'm not like in this kind of
woe is me space I just you know I want
to be able to
be as loving as I can and I know that
sometimes I have to examine
relationships in my life to see where I
have hang-ups
but yeah I was just embarrassed of him
you know the way he's his mind and my
dad was a handsome man you know he had a
uh he had a lovely girlfriend Miss
Maggie and she would make us some she
had that she lived in a nice place man
ever when I went to her place it was
like the nicest apartment we'd ever been
in big tall ceilings men you could have
a whole nother [ __ ] room in the
ceiling the ceiling was so high I said
damn just give me a hammock I'll go live
up there give me four hammocks you know
I'll just I'll just tarzan around up
there i'll build a little kitchenette up
there halfway up the wall give me four
hammocks i'll live in the corner of a
ceiling and she took care
davin he's real old you know she you
know she was probably out six she would
probably sixty and my dad was you know
at that point he's eighty five or
something or she prob about sixty three
and she was fancy she was like a high
society woman you know and in New
Orleans and that's still very you know
they got the fancy people down there but
she was a good woman you know and she
loved my dad and uh and they were
friends and yeah but I just remembered
seeing him like you know walking around
he you know I remember I'd sleep over
there sometimes at her house in the
middle of the night and my dad would get
up to go to the restroom and I'd see him
in like the window and like the moon
like she had these big windows that face
right out on the Mississippi River man
she lived in a I don't even know what it
was it was over there and uh across the
river across the Mississippi over there
and um I uh I can't remember it right
now kind of by Gretna but right off the
right by the river by the ferry anyway
so and I would see my dad walk I could
see him walk and he was just old you
know and and I didn't recognize it as
much when he was you know I'd see him
fully clothed all dressed up and he
dressed up real nice every day and then
at night thought see him in his body he
seemed like a dinosaur like an old
dinosaur and I think it made me scared
you know it made me as a kid it just but
it made me angry at him and I didn't
realize this tool just I mean literally
just this week and and then I was
thinking about it even more on the
flight home this morning when this after
this guy last night was telling me he
had a old father and by hearing me talk
about my dad sometimes he could he could
relate and that maybe
you're happy you know made me feel happy
to know that you know we can relate to
each other uh but yeah made me you know
just made me look more my relationship
you know and I could add more memories
with him if I hadn't judged my father so
much you know he wasn't like this or he
you know he couldn't do this he didn't
have anything uh you know I just think
I'm not mad at myself I don't I want you
to know that I'm not like you know I
just I
I could have been a better maybe could
have been a better son to him you know
and I know the circumstances weren't
ideal but but I just maybe could have
hit him could have been a better son to
him sometimes you know I could've had
more pride you know I wish somebody had
taught me to have more pride in my
family when I was young because I didn't
know and then when other kids started
making fun of you know my situation in
the world like you know I joined them
and made fun of my situation as well
instead of having a sense of pride now
that's where you know my parents or the
world or the scenario or whatever
that's where that that's where you know
my father probably he could have done a
better job by helping me have a sense of
pride in our family and maybe he tried
and maybe and and some of those things
just are the way they are but but I
never realized that I was angry at my
dad until I wrote down this this
resentment thing he says I'm angry at my
father and then I have to write why I'm
angry at him so I have to really sit
there and think and I was angry at him
because I didn't know him you never you
know I never got to know him you know
and I know he loved to sit and drink
coffee and speaking Spanish to his
friends you know I know he bought a
Delta 88
off a black dude and had some speakers
in it they were [ __ ] ratchet and he
would just listen to talk radio with the
loudest bass you've ever heard coming
through the neighborhood he never heard
a man roll through the neighborhood with
just the weather report
60% 60% searcher churns oh cloud 40%
churns up hmm
I mean he did it was [ __ ] crazy man
and he liked us you know goof sleep in
his car at the park a lot of times and
uh but I was ashamed of him you know I
was ashamed of of
to my father
and maybe it was a safety mechanism for
me too because I was afraid that if I
got to know him that I knew he was gonna
die just knew how time worked but I have
to look at this I have to look at that
relationship of my life because if
because it it affects the way today how
I look at time
it affects like how I look at age how I
look at you know wanting to have a
family and not one you know if I have
this built-up fear somewhere deep inside
of me that I'm not going to be able to
create a loving relationship with a
child
it comes from a scenario that's
irregular like an old very old man
having a son but if I let that faster in
me without examining it then it could
affect whenever if I decide to have a
son or not at all or have a child so I
have to look at those things but I was
embarrassed to my father you know um um
what else I wrote I had a list here of
things because I wrote this stuff to
hang on about my resentments
you know I'm and then I get upset
sometimes that I don't remember him and
I was going right in adolescence and
teen and you know getting erect and all
of that and I started doing masturbation
and whatever you know 13 12 bra his dick
City you could look at every state in
the universe's and he look at any map
when you're a kid at 13 years old bra
and his dick City population yeah boy
but yeah I mean I was ashamed of my
father and then I just realized that I
miss him
you know I realized that I judged him
and I realized by looking through some
of the things that I was just pretty
judgmental and I don't know where that
judgment came from or how it started I'm
not ashamed him I'm not mad at myself of
it you know I'm not but I'm glad that
I'm able to see it a little bit now that
I was judgmental towards people that
loved me because
you know I was afraid to it because I
was afraid cuz I didn't know how to do
that you know I don't know how to love
them
and by and by learning here's the thing
by learning what my sure my father had a
bunch of faults he shouldn't had a kid
at that age or or he I'm glad he did
though it wouldn't what I mean he
shouldn't him I'm glad he did if he
didn't I don't exist so but he maybe he
should have thought more about it maybe
he did you know I don't know maybe he
thought I know he thought he was gonna
live to like a hundred you know he
always say that so he'd always like to
kind of guarantee me that but
but I learned through this through doing
this process like why I'm angry at my
father I was ashamed of him I was
embarrassed to him I can't apologize to
him you know I can't love him he was
selfish
you know I'm angry cuz our relationship
wasn't what I wanted I think that's one
thing from the gate I realized though
our relationship this isn't when I want
to have a father-son relationship so I'm
not gonna care about it that much you
know but
and then sometimes I thought a lot of
times like I used my dad because he was
so old that even if I did like regular
kid kind of mischief around him it
always came off like I always felt bad
about it you know cuz if you joke around
with it you you know you say you hide
something from your dad if he's thirty
it's fine he'll find that [ __ ]
but you hide something from your dad and
he's 78 you hide his car keys they would
he could look for a month so I think I
uh I developed this deep sense of like
feeling bad about myself because I would
do regular things that kid would do but
then I would see the effect that they
would have on an older person and then I
would feel so bad about it because a
kid's gonna do those things no matter
what but then when you see that this old
person can't deal with it and then it
makes you feel bad you know so I think I
developed this sense of like shame a lot
that kind of lives in me but I don't
realize it unless I start to look at
these relationships in my life and so
anyway that's something that I'm
learning to do like in my 12 steps you
know but but anyway let's get into some
calls man but I just want to say thank
you to the young man that shared what he
was thinking the other night estate
agent you know and then and then another
couple came up there and they got
engaged man and oh man she was so happy
you know I saw this woman she teared up
and she was crying and you know the guy
was all he was so excited and man it's
cool
you know I'm blood you know I'm blessed
man I am blessed to uh I'm blessed to be
able to feel I'm happy to be able to
even feel things I'm like you know it's
beautiful for me right now as I get to
still have a feeling about my father you
know and it's so funny as soon as I
started making this list the other day
and thinking about this stuff
immediately a lot more memories of my
father came into me and in my brain in a
in a more comfortable space you know a
lot more things came into me where in
the memories I was more loving of him
now even immediately then I was like you
know the meetings were softer they had
the the memories were softer they had
more of a curve to him and this wasn't
such a just a little bit of lesson less
90-degree angles around my heart let's
take a couple calls man so I mean what
I'm talking about
but man I'm excited for those tour dates
they're gonna be fun some of these are
theatres man I can't even believe this I
cannot even believe this so I want to
thank you all those tickets are gonna be
available to a Tuesday at 10:00 a.m.
your local time Theo von comm slash tour
where you can get those tickets I'll
tell you it is right now that today's
episode is brought to you by Skillshare
is an online learning community for
creators create create tours with more
than 25,000 classes and design business
and more you'll discover countless ways
to fuel your curiosity creativity and
you know career take classes in social
media marketing mobile photography
creative writing even illustration
change your life if you want to you got
to go to Community College even got a
drive over there to Toledo State you
ain't got to do that you can take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain professional skills
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching those new goals
join the millions of students today if
you're thinking about doing crime or
something you got a gun you got a needle
put it down pick up skill share and we
have a special offer just for our
listener get two months of Skillshare
for free 60 days of skills
that's right skill share is offering
this past weekend listeners two months
of unlimited access for over 25,000
classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash Theo von thank you
guys for your support man uh yeah man I
just yeah I got it just got me thinking
about the parental stuff and family
stuff and just you know uh and just like
you know just just judgment and how much
it keeps me away from others I can feel
that sometimes even still today you know
I know I'm not doing good when I start
getting real judgmental because judgment
keeps me away from you it keeps me away
from someone oh look at them look at
that
I'll look there like that oh they have
that oh now sometimes it worked to
inspire me you know I judge the rich I
judge the greedy you know and some of
those and sometimes it works to inspire
me and that's the I feel like those
things are necessary but I'm gonna point
in my life now what I'm able to look and
see okay is this still serving me well
or is this just a thing that's keeping
me away from people you know and then it
goes down over why why are you so afraid
to have somebody care about you why are
you so afraid to care about someone
that's the devil out there making you
believe that or feel that a seitan maybe
that's Lucifer brah
that's Lucifer that darkness sniffer and
they think you the whole life you think
oh I'll just keep judging and keeping
people at a distance but guess what
there's this there's this there's this
thing in the distance making you think
oh you get that that you win somehow
that or that I win somehow by doing that
I'm not saying you I'm saying me but
then I get to the end of my life and
I'll realize you know what I didn't win
anything by doing that that was a that
was a trick and the only thing I won
was being alone or being less connected
to others you know and not only did I
miss out cook could I could I miss out
on caring about people but I missed out
on feeling probably a lot of the love
that people had for me
you
because there's something right there
wrapped up neck their next-door
neighbor's their cheek-to-cheek their
conjoined twins when when I when I don't
when I can't love someone when I don't
want I judge and I keep someone away
from me
I'll keep me away from them I keep me
away from them and also what the [ __ ] I
don't know the [ __ ] I'm talking about
let's get into some questions man I but
I don't know man you know
yet I'm not being hard on myself because
you know why I'm not saying woe is me
this or that I'm not saying that I'm
just saying that I'm just saying I know
that there's if I'm resentment about
something I'm angry about something I
need to go look at why I'm angry about
it
and if I can eventually find a way that
I had some say in it some then at least
it's now it's in my control so instead
of being angry at my dad because he was
so old and I didn't get to a proper
father-son relationship instead I can
take a little bitty piece and say oh
well you know what when I was like 15 16
I could have probably been a better son
at some points then it puts a little bit
of it on me now it's now I can have
ownership of it and now I can go
apologize you know to my father's grave
if I want to and let him know and not
that I'm like because then it just give
me ownership now I'm in control of our
relationship again and now I can rebuild
memories and and now I don't have that
now there's no anger between us anymore
you know now it's an opportunity for us
to for my brain and heart to be like ah
man good that right-angle ain't there
that right turn that stoplight those
seven stop signs you got built up at
this intersection of your emotions it's
not there anymore and it's just a
beautiful curve man and you can feel the
love you can feel the love man let's get
a couple calls that came in man these
came in this one came in before I went
to Florida I didn't get to it oh we're
from Orlando but up and what up Neil
from Orlando and I'll say this about
your area Neil that's a bright area
Orlando that is just damn bright ganna
Stan you need sunglasses your sunglasses
better be have contact lenses you better
have on a hat a cowboy hat you better
bring an awning you better have some
dude park right behind you with a camper
and if and throw that awning out because
grandma's skin and catfish bro and it's
still sunny out and we need that
cover one of the brightest cities I've
ever been in in America that sort of
land Oh onward now with LSU as well
start got some questions about your LSU
days but honestly I'll save those for
later I just want to think oh no you're
going to be down in Palm Beach this
weekend as long as they welcome to
Florida welcome to the Sunshine State
watch out for Florida man
Florida man is real out here it's a
spirit that possesses men women children
and animals so watch out don't trust any
small children or small animals while
you're out here take care yourself Bo
have a good weekend love you game gang
love you too brother gang gang and I
stayed out of the darkness over there
you know I honestly I didn't have a
chance to even get involved in any mess
you know I saw a dude they had a guy at
the bar smoking a cigarette through his
nostril
but with my boy Richard had showed up
and I see he got that you know he got he
got that that par that par one on his
you know he got that neck hole that
oesophageal because if he can't breathe
out here when you smoke your esophagus
out when you blow out your windpipe you
got to go you got to get the air
straight from the neck hole and he's
doing that wedding ring trip but damn do
they also he told me with the wedding
ring trunk with the he told me with the
wedding ring trick that he [ __ ] it up
about four times I had to pump his
stomach just pumping the matrimony out
of that dude because god damn bruh you
send a wedding ring through somebody's
bowels
I mean s that could be grounds for
divorce
but yatta you know I didn't get involved
in anything I saw a couple of kids maybe
look like it could have been uh a real
small man dressed up faking it you know
trying to find at it to catch on to with
his lips trying to get that sip of leche
that cone let's say that Calle de leche
that Street milk oh god I can't believe
I'm just swallowing [ __ ] mucus point
I am a lizard but ya didn't give in to
any temptation man I mean given any
temptation man you know uh I mean a
couple I got like some you know couple
wild cats somebody sent me a picture de
booty and the dm's and all of that and I
maybe flirted with disaster considered
it but I stayed out I stayed out of it
but one thing I have been doing is dr.
Perlmutter sugar-free universe or
whatever it's called Jesus Christ dude
I'll [ __ ] tie myself to a rocket and
shoot myself towards the actual Milky
Way right now hoping it's a sweet candy
out in space cuz yeah brah being all
sugar is hard dude maybe Florida man is
just some guy who's trying to be on uh
on that Kido cuz do you [ __ ] rocket
here somebody oh I could hear somebody
[ __ ] unwrap a jolly rancher from
probably about 80 yards
what is that lime dude you hear of sugar
you want to talk about crack you want
you know what I'm saying
step on a crack baby break your mama's
back that sugar let's hear another call
that came in as always the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and I think you guys so much
for your support of this podcast
[Music]
man I'm so grateful man you know I'm
grateful that we have this fun little
world on and I think we're gonna do cool
stuff in the world manner but I believe
that and I know I'm the one that talks a
lot but
but I think but I think about us
let's take more without the others
what's up boy Adam calling you from Boca
Raton Florida what's up Adam Boca Raton
maybe that's the rats mouth that's what
they called it and Boca Raton is a great
way to find you a GILF or a good GILF
that great grandmother I'd like them hmm
fornicate home word you know that rat's
mouth I'm gang gang boy Rat King a Ling
Sun in el building when peers show last
night in West Palm Beach man I went solo
and next thing you know I got that two
little girls sitting right next to me
she's also going in solo and next thing
you know man
we after watching your awesome show we
we go out we get some drinks and and
well we we spent the night together in
there whoa whoa whoa whoa that's what
I'm talking about
they'll be doing it out here we doing it
out here the dark arts broad we [ __ ]
dropping flashlights on the dark hearts
boy we got people getting married on the
stage we got young bucks solo dolo
and now this guy got him a little dime
bra this nickel found him a dime let's
hear more brother I got you to thank for
that bro so uh yeah I just wanted to
thank you thanks for coming down there
and go get that head of rough young
young gang gang baby get that he had our
dude that's cool man that makes me feel
good you know and even though I'm
masturbating on Friday night on Saturday
night I didn't so that made me feel
pretty good too to not do that I got one
day but I bet I've still off the
pornography but I'm just on that bust
you know I got back on the bus truck all
aboard you know and I bust it out man
but
I'm glad that you found somebody I'm
glad that yeah look and when we stay in
the good space man I do believe that
good things can happen for us you know
and we get tempted man we see that
wooden spoon stirring up all the goodies
but we don't see the hand that's
stirring it the hand got dirty
fingernail polish on it and that hands
got a the knuckles of a of a leper
and I don't know what a leper is
actually but I think it's but it's just
got you know that's the devil let's hear
more homeward your hero is getting there
so there was my birthday and it snowed
here in Calgary Alberta
dang Jesse and look yeah and I god bless
you up there in Edmonton man and I'll
say this man they people think it's not
wild up there in Canada dude while we
were in the sunshine over there in West
Palm Beach riding four-wheelers with
riff raff Ian's with the giraffe himself
with ken griffey jr. and Edmonton's up
there in the snow long word happy
birthday belated but like three feet of
snow it is like the last time I saw this
most films are birthday I nearly
overdosed brother
things have changed mom and it's like
going on seven a time right now and I'm
wait hold on oh sorry I couldn't hear
something else play it again
like three feet of snow it is like the
last time I saw it is my birthday
I nearly overdosed brother things have
changed mom and it's like going on 7
a.m. right now and I'm awake and I'm
sober in like two years
but something about this day like with
all this snow on the ground makes me
feel kind of like I'm higher so you know
I'm coming down like it's just a weird
thing to think that like imagine being
awake in this moment because your heart
is racing and your jaws grunting and you
got a limp dick but you're gonna try to
jerk off anyway oh yeah dude
oh yeah and I got that fat Pat down
between my legs you know and
I'm jerking on it's like man is trying
to uh like trying to do CPR on a [ __ ]
Saint Bernard that's been uh that has
not been missing meals you know what I'm
saying that thick canine broth like
trying to do CPR on that thick canine
when he's in a coma in that [ __ ] coma
but no it is man it's a beautiful hi
brothers a beautiful heart that you can
get by being and being in the same exact
spot you were but by being a different
person I've had that feeling before man
yeah I hated that man being awake 7 a.m.
9 a.m.
hot on the cocaine man still just just a
just a carpet surfing for a little
little little nugget to that blow seen
if anything's left snorting [ __ ]
popcorn half a popcorn carnal banking
him was a little rock yeah but now man
you get a feeling and it's feeling is
good there's a different high inside of
you you know that's awesome I appreciate
you sharing man congratulations on your
sobriety brother and if you aren't sober
don't I don't want you thinking you
can't be here you can't listen I don't
look I mean if you [ __ ] if you got a
if you got an 8 B Z on your right now
I'll hold the back of your neck while
you do a long line son while you [ __ ]
just take another George Washington's
wig right up your nostril that [ __ ]
white fight put it right up into your
brain now [ __ ] muster Douglas and
that's just gonna [ __ ] punch in the
skull a couple times dude look more
power to you alright let's take another
call here here we go
what a pleasure CEO thank you for
answering the call this is Eric on
Orange Beach what's up Eric Orange Beach
man and that's a lease to go over there
and uh first Spring Break when I was in
high school and it's one kid named Billy
and he's I don't know if he has now
called problem but I don't I don't know
if he doesn't but he broke out a window
one time
in our hotel room our motel room and
then I think he went to jail or
something we sold all of his clothes
while he was in jail we sold everything
out of his luggage on the strip all
we're down here just hanging out
tried to microdose under on the
mushrooms and I think I overdosed but
anyway hell yeah brah dude that's my
thing if I'm micro docent I'm more CRO
docent son one drop for me one drop for
me
next thing you next thing you know I'm
nine drops deep I'm 70 drops deep you're
like I am run you supposed to be micro
dosing you got all your clothes off man
what the [ __ ] is going on it's 2:00 in
the afternoon next thing you do bye
buddy and a pair of needle-nose somebody
pull a tooth that had a problem with but
never mind that just want to let you
know back spin in the back episodes hope
I don't run out but really enjoy what
you're doing
alright then he did Gang Gang brother
look man if you pulling out a tooth on
shrooms I think that's what I gathered
there then you doing good work baby
anybody that could bust up bust around
on their own enamel I wasn't that brave
you know you that's you like a baby
Kevorkian out there if you're thinking
about if you're willing to pull one of
your body parts out of your potty when
you high on shrooms buddy that's what
I'm talking about
that's dentist the Menace bro you don't
one right now oh dude that's the thing
that's a new deal you could do [ __ ]
dental work on people that's all gackt
out of their brains or whatever dude
open up that 2:00 a.m. that that
emergency clinic people that's [ __ ] up
they pop in you do whatever take out an
appendix you know I'm saying take an ear
off van Gogh somebody because if you the
guy man you the guy cuz that's brave to
pull your own tooth down when you're
high on mushrooms man damn I hope you
kept it I bet you gave it to somebody
now the
the smooth the smooth move is giving it
somebody you're in love with you know
what I'm saying
drop that incisor into a girl's palm
make her feel something special because
anybody could throw you know throat put
a wiener in a lady but to find a lady
and hit her with that [ __ ] molar baby
one of those strong white mouth dicks
now that's a real man thank you for
sharing ma'am
yeah Micro means might grow if you're
going a few macro dos and rough you know
that's when you're doing self surgery
down there in Orange Beach but let's
take another call nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three as always
is the is the hotline that you can hit
and let's go what do you got Minnesota
thank you for calling Josh
I appreciate your call man all right
struggling listen [ __ ] I heard your
podcast with well you had the best of
friends pushing you up and making you
wonderful oh I need that so much in my
life right now I'm recovering from
alcohol so well 80 years haven't done a
hard drugs in eight years
a smoked pot s not a drug but I recently
spent a season pills again man I've
dealt with suicidal tendencies been in
and out of hospitals just look him first
I don't even know man just looking for
some positives and this negative that
that I deal with home today Gang Gang
lamp
gang gang brother let me listen to get
at the beginning catch your name I think
of his Josh Minnesota hey Josh man I
appreciate your call man
I hope you can hear your own voice right
now I want to because if you're
listening to this episode then you're
here let's hear some of your own voice
again daughter struggling listen [ __ ] I
heard your podcast with well you had the
best of friends pushing you on
recovering from alcohol or eighty years
haven't done a hard drugs in high eight
years a smoke pot that's not a truck mmm
but I recently spent a season pills
again man I've dealt with suicide yeah
and I just want you to hear your own
voice man just you know I don't know how
if that can help you or not but
yeah I think the first thing I think
whenever I hear you calling thank you
for calling man thank you
you know it's brave of you to do and
that is a that's nice of you to care
enough to share you know and it makes me
feel sad you know it makes me feel sad
that you don't feel good but it's a big
problem that's going on man you know
it's powerful those pills and those and
we get polluted you know we get polluted
and the end and and when we're sick we
can't help ourselves you know it sounds
like you have a real history of taking
care of yourself you know you had eight
years no alcohol eight years no hard
drugs you're able to use pot and monitor
yourself and I'm not saying that any of
those you know to each their own journey
but yeah may you may be fighting a dark
art right now that you can't get up on
daddy you know sometimes there's a camel
that you can't control you know a friend
of mine drew a camel for me one time and
sometime a camel have two months and you
sit in the middle but sometime a camel
does have one [ __ ] huge ass hump and
there's nowhere for you to sit and both
of them will put a sign out front to say
camel rides but the second camel is just
taking your [ __ ] money
the second camel is taking you for a
ride it's not giving you anything and I
know you know you're in a tough spot man
I mean it sounds like all I can offer is
experience from things I've experienced
I haven't experienced what you're
experiencing but you know when I was
struggling with drug use I got into
12-step and I got into that kind of
program stuff that helped me
another detox and recovery centers and
things you can reach out to and and just
don't be ashamed if you have to do that
you know don't be ashamed nobody should
ever we shouldn't make we shouldn't make
each other feel ashamed for you know for
sharing our struggles and trying to get
through them you know we're not the news
bro we're not the you know we're not
this society that things said oh
everybody's perfect and beats them down
when we're not we don't do that you know
we don't we don't shoot our wounded bro
so but I'll check in on you this week
man I'll drop your buzz and check in on
you and see what's up but uh just be
good to yourself you know you deserve it
and take care of yourself man and you
can do it I mean you did eight years the
homework is there if you look at your
history it feels like the homework is
there to me so you just had a tough spot
man he could get through it though and I
think there's a lot of bright spots out
in front of you and man what a loving
place for you to be in Minnesota so many
I mean I'll you want to talk about a
place I know there Minnesota nice and
behind-the-scenes okay but there's a lot
of loving people up there and a lot of
people with big hearts man and uh if
you're saying that big right now find
somebody who's is you know because
sometimes we're fighting the power
that's greater than ourselves so just
don't feel like you
not doing a good job of fighting it
sometimes you know it's not a fair fight
sometime the camel that you're riding
don't have a place for you to sit you
can't you can't sit you know you can't
sit on you know it's got to be a curve
man gang but uh let's take another call
or two man that's a heavy one man nine
eighty five six six four nine five zero
three hey Theo man this is Levi Hovis
Tedrow from coming out of Southern
Indiana
what's up Levi thank you for calling
they're from southern Indiana man
homeward and that's the same state as
Jim Gaffigan is from and Little J gaff
was in here last weekend man we had a
nice time Oh word um I was just curious
to what you thought about rollercoasters
what would you think if the Martians
came down some day and they seen us just
riding on rollercoasters and bungee
jumping and skydiving and stuff like
that just risking our lives like you
know just to get a little adrenaline
push do you think I would be you think
they would think that was stupid or or
do you think they'd be kind of
interested in that or do you think
they'd do kind of the same thing and not
necessarily just Martians but you know
any kind of foreign being at this
universe what do you think I was just
like to hear your thoughts on on what
you think they would uh how they would
feel about that and if they would want
to do the same kind of thing or if
they've done it before thanks brother
Gang Gang coming out of Bloomington
Indiana I I appreciate you gang gang
Bloomington man I think they got a
school there so they got a big nursing
school over there I think that's the
place si you know Indiana State maybe
I'm not sure it doesn't matter thank you
for calling man that's a great question
you know when I looked at it I've heard
what brought a lian's are gonna think we
are idiots I think or maybe that's the
easy way to think maybe that's the easy
way maybe that's the easy idea maybe
they're gonna be infatuated maybe
there's have really cool rock
and they don't know [ __ ] because if you
really think about it aliens are gonna
be so technologically advanced that as
beings they're gonna be inept because
the more technologically advanced we get
we tend to get more inept more
comfortable more lemming-like you know
we're just ants we become way more ants
than we do Antron ORS you fill me
so if aliens come here they gonna be all
shuttled up I mean you're talking about
everybody's got a [ __ ] even their
shitty uncle is an Elon Musk you know
everybody's got that technological
capabilities so when then bad cats get
out here they going on mmm Burger King
they probably all gonna be all jacked up
on Burger King smoking cigarettes bro I
mean we think that they're gonna be so
advanced they all know how to work the
controls but once you take that gasoline
out of it out of that you know machine
will lean that they're in it's gonna be
a different story but but but the other
side is that they'll be so advanced but
yet bungee-jumping we're [ __ ] dude
tying yourself to a rope and jumping off
of somebody's crane that's probably very
cheaply insured it's like Chapa KO on a
rope bruh sounds risky as [ __ ]
I mean they're gonna that's a great
question and dude I'll tell you some of
the truth what I've heard about aliens
I've heard that some of my black friends
that said that they got issues with
aliens
apparently there's beef or something
right there
and I was shocked when I heard like what
like yeah man
cuz aliens what are they gonna do you
know they think a lot of black people
and aliens they [ __ ] got beef I guess
so
[ __ ] man I mean I think it would be a
good fight probably but who knows bro
who knows man let's take one more call
and and I think that'll be it for today
hey steer this is clay calling it from
south Louisiana
what's up clay and I love that dude
that's one thing I love about Louisiana
you get somebody that's named after a
soil after a you get somebody named clay
dirt you get somebody named after a type
of weather sunny breezy dusty hail hail
Watkins of it air out there I for a
million parish you got Blizzard Jackson
black gal that I went to school with she
got a couple beautiful children now who
else man everybody and you know you get
down in the South especially in
Louisiana you get those with those wild
names rivers you get a boy named rivers
drowning Johansson we had a [ __ ]
German fellow showed up drowning
Johansson I mean this kind of water
related onward driving over that Jeff
Lloyd basin right now yeah yeah that a
chop a lot of basin man dang I just
walked out of LSU my last my last class
gonna be graduating made sense I just
wanted to thank you I'd be a driving
from last year's bat Rouge every Tuesday
Thursday go to class
it's not like thank you keeping me
entertained on this hour drives me my
brother really appreciate everything you
do get a lot of your laughs out of you
not out of out of juice but with you I
guess anyway love you brother
gang gang gang gang man go Tigers
Wow well that's nice you to say man uh
you know when I was young and I was at
and I was at LSU like I always I didn't
fit in that great and so sometimes some
of my experience there wasn't super but
but I love Louisiana and I love the city
and I love the team I did I think I was
just a nervous kid you know something
none of my experiences we're gonna be
super congratulations man
congratulations
wow what a feeling what a moment you
just took us to that moment when you go
to your last college class like now what
am I gonna be an adult am I gonna go
travel you know what about this
relationship I'm in way did something
happen with that if that's going on Who
am I now these big training wheels of
American society they you know you've
kind of treaded them as far as you can
and where are you then what are you
gonna do now Ethan and B that's exciting
man well I'm glad I was able to help you
make you laugh in it and whatever facet
man you know I'm a clown but I'm a
closet though you know uh you know so
you know it's funny that's my dad that's
how I laughed at my father sometimes
sometimes he made me laugh cuz he was
funny but sometimes I laughed at him
is a great city and it's also a state so
I'll [ __ ] them I think I should go back
to LSU um but uh you know sometime
people give this out they give us such
our rap but man there's a lot of loving
people there and I'd take that any day
over sometimes at the framework that
we're building in other places where
it's I mean Los Angeles has turned into
an airport this city is and it's the
airport once you land at the airport
it's the airport when you get home it's
the airport way you never let's just a
huge airport it's got that feeling let
me go and let me do that link hit the
back there's always a line everybody
this and then and [ __ ] and here come the
guy with the carts and for people in
working these all know that you know you
know everybody's slacking over there in
the wheelchairs and doing this and that
but uh enough about me man
congratulations dude you got your whole
world ahead of you you do what you want
take time if I could go back in time I I
wouldn't put so much pressure on myself
to do things I would take a little bit
more time to do some traveling you know
I wouldn't think that just because if
somebody else is going straight into
some big job and I wasn't that that I
wasn't gonna have a good life or that
things weren't going to be you have a
lot of time you have a lot of time it's
not life or death right now for you it's
just life and I know you didn't ask for
that those suggestions but but yeah man
you time is man the time is the number
one currency boy
it's a beautiful currency and
congratulations to you to you your
brother man shout out to him Lisette Lee
bone throwing rule a boy y'all be good
down in Lafayette shout out to my boy
Richie hike over there and and all the
good people over here in south Louisiana
all the people are in Lake Charles the
greatest city in America to take a nap
in Lake Charles put you to sleep
that's rocking-chair country but a lot
of good people a lot of good recipes a
lot of good music a lot of good stories
a lot of big smiles and I'm happy to be
from from a place that has those sorts
of things what else man oh I saw this
news thing
Google's wing wins the first FAA
approval for drone delivery so you want
to talk about EO TWU baby the end of the
Wow
let's talk about it what's happening man
drones drew a we going oh so we drone it
you see me drone and people gonna be
[ __ ] shootin drones am I thought it
was a mallard I thought it was a mallard
with a briefcase and that's that Google
wing or that's that Amazon of flight
what's good what if somebody drops a
[ __ ] huh you know somebody drop a
couple accidentally when in a Google
wing drops a couple of vibrato is into
um into a preschool yard now you got
children down there beating each other
with sexual you know for Brad errs in
each other and what else man what if you
see a [ __ ] you know somebody drop a
wig in wit Nam you know into a tug of
war facility and now you got a couple of
people just just stretching out a new
year's we've just two teams just [ __ ]
locked out
is it safe to have just stuff flying
through the air what did you order a
couple cans of wd-40 and the doors
locked and the dang little electric bird
drops in [ __ ] down the [ __ ] chimney
that that little electric bird dropped
some things down the chimney that's
gonna be WD 8,000 blow your damn
homestead up if you got the fire going
if you got a kettle of tea on you
chamomile and the next thing you know
you I see you in because everybody's
burnt out cuz you ordered something
and if you can trust these things man
you know what if they would if you
ordered from the food place and they
drop a damn ham hock into a vegan
household then what suddenly they're all
happy because they got a Jawa ham on him
now somebody got a little [ __ ] you
know the kid run out there and sneak
that hock into his room because he's
tired of just let us sit around with his
folks and that kind of like squash make
everybody happy and grilled zucchinis
Braille y'all need to tighten up so I
guess there is some good sides of it cuz
I'll be dang well if I wouldn't sit at a
window and watch a couple kids who had
just been forced into veganism man watch
a brother in two you know your brother
and sister two children sit there and
watch two children sit there and share a
damn ham hock that came from the heavens
Oh Google Wang they might be on the Sun
I think there were things I didn't get
to I think there were things that I did
again the tour dates the cities they're
all out there again we got some new
hitters up at the Oh van comm / store
you can go get a cool shirt if you want
and again thanks for listening to me
just say [ __ ] I mean I honestly don't
know what I'm talking about but uh but
man what a show what do we can a guy I
met a girl there and no no you know no
me to [ __ ] they had fun you know some
people came out they had fun people
enjoying themselves enjoying their lives
people got engaged on stage a young guy
just graduate just got finished his
final class and drove away from campus
for that last time on a sunny afternoon
in southern Louisiana or anywhere any
city any town any countryside
a new experience a man struggling with
drugs he's fought hard but now they got
these pills out there
I shouldn't be making these damn pills
it's messed up it's messed up man that
[ __ ] makes me mad but we're better than
that as people it's like suddenly we
become companies and we book and and we
act like it's something else
companies just a couple people
with the devil arts man but we're making
it and I'm gonna close out with that you
guys be good to yourselves may you
deserve it you know and uh and just
thanks that's all I can say man this is
Bishop gun with making it
I ain't seen home in about a hundred
days I can almost tell mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
kill me yet I still get where I'm bound
go
you
bacon raw bacon
[Music]
we got this man
most all of my plans slip right through
my hands and walk up next to me
it's true huh if this bottle was an hour
glance I'm sleeping I'm about an hour
I should've put it down
[Music]
but how
making good time
[Music]
you hear those drumbeats man you heard
them in the background right there take
you back look quick you hear I'm right
there
this drumbeats man it's a son of a man
that couldn't beat addiction you know
[Music]
but beautiful things come out of
everything man and they can you know we
just don't give up you know and now we
got a beautiful thing here we get the
music
[Music]
I hate seen old men palpable to date I
can almost hear mama
[Music]
we got this man if you can't love
yourself you know we can if we can't
love ourselves we can at least try to
let other people love us until we can
mean you guys be good man I love you
take care of yourselves and I'll see you
guys in New York City in New York City
this week so I'm excited about that you
know we're going New York City so you'll
be there with me okay
you